the Russians moved in after the
Americans moved out in a deliberate
withdrawal the city of members is
Moscow's latest victory in Syria its
military police now patrols a front line
that separates the Turkish and Syrian
army's their presence stops a Turkish
led military advance towards the city
which sits on the m4 highway a main
logistics and commercial route that runs
to the Iraqi border the city also
connects the east of the Euphrates with
the rest of northern Syria the Russian
move disrupts anchors plan to create
what it calls a safe zone to allow
refugees who are afraid to live under
President Bashar al-assad to rule to
return home yalla I hope very soon we
will liberate a field for ma'am Beach to
Iraqi border and guaranteed at 1 million
in the first phase and 2 million in the
second phase will return to Syria but it
is the russian-backed Syrian army which
returned to the Northeast restoring
control for the first time since 2013
the abrupt pullout by the US military
forced its longtime partners the Kurdish
led Syrian democratic forces to cede
control of territory to Damascus for
protection the SDF is the target of the
Turkish military operation in Northeast
Syria the armed group is largely made up
of fighters from the Syrian Kurdish YPG
organization that turkey calls
terrorists because of its links with the
PKK Turkey wants to push the group away
from the border but it is fighting back
so far the turkey led forces have not
been able to complete the first phase of
the operation that involves securing the
120 kilometer long and 30 kilometer deep
pocket along the border
Turkey is also coming under diplomatic
pressure the United States and the
European Union have imposed sanctions
Washington is calling on Turkey to stop
what it calls an invasion and agree to a
ceasefire so far the reaction from
Turkish officials has been one of
defiance
they say the presence of the YPG along
Turkey's border is a national security
threat sanctions may hurt but they feel
the danger coming from Syria is worse
the SDF once controlled 30% of Syria
where millions live an area rich in oil
agriculture and water the UN says 160
thousand of them are on the move in what
was once a relatively peaceful and
stable corner of Syria Russia and
turkeys local allies are battling on
several fronts russia says it doesn't
approve turkeys military moves in Syria
and won't accept its permanent presence
there seems to be serious differences
between the two countries who are
supposed to be working together in Syria
but diplomatic channels remain open and
members could be leveraged Zanic other
al Jazeera on the Turkish Syria border